[Aplausos]
tienes de vosotros sabrías decirme qué
es esto y no os preocupéis entonces que
responder en voz alta solamente levantar
las manos
sí bueno imagino que muchos de vosotros
habréis acertado
efectivamente es nuestra galaxia la vía
láctea
una de las experiencias que más recuerdo
cuando era pequeño fue cuando subí a las
cañadas del teide de noche y ahí a 2000
metros de altura con un cielo
completamente despejado pude ver esto
por primera vez
naturalmente no era la primera vez que
miraba el cielo pero como niño decida
que soy siquiera la primera vez que
podía haber algo así y la verdad que
para mí fue fascinante desde entonces no
he dejado de preguntarme que hay ahí
fuera en el espacio y cómo sería llegar
a las estrellas
hay fuera hay sin duda un número
inimaginable de misterios por encontrar
y por resolver mundos que visitar y
convertir en nuestro hogar historias que
crear y que vivir y quién sabe quizá
también vida más allá de la que
conocemos en nuestro planeta tierra
seguro que muchos de vosotros estas
ideas os han rondado por la cabeza
alguna vez
llegaremos alguna vez a ser una especie
multi planeta os imagináis las
implicaciones de eso o quizá hayáis
sentido algo parecido al mirar por un
microscopio o al aprender cómo funciona
el cuerpo humano o quizás al probar
comidas de otros países en mi caso el
deseo de responder estas preguntas ha
condicionado muchas de las decisiones
que tomado en mi vida he pensado mucho
de cuál es el origen de estas
inquietudes de los mecanismos que nos
llevan a plantearnos preguntas y a
partir de ellas elegir nuestro camino en
la vida y creo que puede reducirse a una
emoción
curiosidad una de las características
más valiosas y bonitas que tiene el ser
humano y qué más le hace ser humano de
hecho
y el primero de los ingredientes del que
os quiero hablar hoy os voy a hablar de
dos de ellos
para mí la curiosidad es esa fuerza
motriz que nos hace plantearnos
preguntas constantemente y aprender de
cosas nuevas
no os hablo de esa curiosidad mundana
que nos obliga a empezar el siguiente
capítulo de una serie que estamos viendo
cuando termina la anterior o que nos
hace mirar por encima del hombro a ver
qué está leyendo la persona que tenemos
al lado en el metro por curiosidad sino
de una curiosidad mucho más pura vale la
que nos hace que podamos pasar horas
enfrascado en un problema que nos
interesa o metidos en nuestro trabajo
también leyendo un libro
y creo que la mejor analogía para
describir esta curiosidad pura es el
espíritu despreocupado y juguetón de un
niño que quiere aprender que quiere
saber de pequeños cada novedad no es
maravilla
queremos tocarlo todo aprender cómo
funciona cada cosa y también meter los
dedos en el enchufe a ver qué pasa o
tirar el jarrón de nuestra madre al
suelo a ver cómo suena oa ver la cara
que pone nuestra madre
de mayores
nos ayuda a revelar nuestros verdaderos
intereses y nuestros propósitos en la
vida y nos ayuda a encontrarlos y nos
anima a avanzar hacia ellos imagino que
muchos de vosotros estaréis estudiando o
habéis terminado estudiar hace poco y
espero que nuestras pasiones lo que
realmente os motiva y interesa marcar a
pesar enormemente en la decisión de que
estudiar en mi trabajo en la universidad
veo que los estudiantes más curiosos son
los que desarrollan un espíritu crítico
más potente y la capacidad de aprender
de forma más efectiva
desde un punto de vista evolutivo esa
curiosidad nos ha hecho aprender de
nuestro entorno para aprovecharnos de él
y ayudarnos a sobrevivir nos convirtió
en exploradores que nos hizo recorrer el
mundo entero y asentarnos en los lugares
más remotos inhóspitos desde los polos
hasta los desiertos nos hizo
descubridores inventores científicos y
por supuesto nos dio la ciencia y la
tecnología creo que no cabe duda que sin
curiosidad no seríamos hoy lo que somos
y no existiría una civilización
hay personas en el mundo que destacan
por su gran sentido de la curiosidad y
por lo que han conseguido gracias a ella
de hecho imaginan este sentido de la
curiosidad como su atributo más
importante como por ejemplo el personaje
famoso que siempre afirmaba repetidas
veces que no poseía ni un cerebro
especial ni era superdotado y que tenía
ningún otro tipo de cualidad especial
salvo ser infinitamente curioso por todo
lo que le rodeaba sabíais decirme de
quién es esta frase y de nuevo muy bien
efectivamente habéis acertado es de
nuestro amigo albert
o esta otra persona de aquí este hombre
que quizás sea menos conocido pero cuya
pasión por entender cómo podemos viajar
por las estrellas y cómo sería llegar a
otros mundos marcó toda su vida y le
hizo dejar una gran huella os presento a
konstantín tsiolkovski nacido en rusia a
finales del siglo 19 y que creció con
las historias de julio verne sobre
viajes a la luna
para él no había nada más importante que
descubrir que había ahí fuera y si sería
posible llevar a la humanidad más allá
de la tierra
movido por estas inquietudes y por estos
deseos él se puso a buscar respuestas e
intentar resolver retos que rodean al
vuelo espacial por ejemplo desarrolló
increíbles trajes presurizados para
astronautas sillas que le permiten a un
astronauta soportar las enormes
aceleraciones o incluso naves espaciales
diseños de naves espaciales que los
protegieran del vacío del espacio y de
las radiaciones que se encuentran allí y
también estaciones orbitales con
invernaderos para cultivar comida y
cosas parecidas pero quizás sin duda la
contribución más importante de este
hombre fue sentar las bases de cómo
funcionan los motores cohete sin los
cuales sería imposible siquiera
plantearnos movernos por el espacio
desarrolló decenas de diseños sobre
cohetes y lanzadores multifase muy
avanzados para su época yarkovsky era
muy consciente de que moverse por el
espacio no es nada sencillo por el vacío
del espacio fijaros voy a intentar
explicar esto desde un ejemplo que
podamos conocer mejor si pensamos por
ejemplo en un coche el coche puede
empujar con las ruedas contra el suelo y
así moverse hacia adelante verdad si
pensamos en un barco el barco también
puede hacer lo mismo con el agua e
incluso un avión puede empujar contra el
aire de la atmósfera pero hay fuera en
el vacío del espacio no hay
absolutamente nada contra lo que empujar
y si queremos movernos no nos queda más
remedio que llevar con nosotros
propulsantes que lanzar en la dirección
contraria a la que queremos movernos
para así conseguirlo
sarkozy pensó mucho en este problema y
le dedicó muchos años de su vida y mucho
esfuerzo y tras pensarlo mucho consiguió
condensar toda la dificultad que
conlleva el viaje espacial en una
ecuación sencilla que es la ecuación del
cohete que hoy en día lleva su nombre
lo que nos ha contado hasta ahora es que
su vida no fue precisamente fácil no fue
un camino de rosas al contrario de
muchos que tienen todas las facilidades
y que también tienen inquietudes pero
sin embargo se quedan a mitad de camino
no llegan a hacer nada porque quizás no
tienen el valor o les puede la pereza
charcos que no tenía mucho pero hizo
mucho más que soñar
él nació en una familia humilde de
campesinos y sólo pudo recibir tres años
de colegio porque a los diez se quedó
sordo por la escarlatina tuvo que
abandonar el colegio pero él decidió
hacerse autodidacta porque tenía que
aprender muchas cosas para conseguir sus
metas
tampoco se vino abajo cuando por ejemplo
una inundación se llevó por delante
todas sus notas de trabajo y tuvo que
empezar prácticamente de cero
creo que si algo que estaría de acuerdo
conmigo en que si bien su enorme
curiosidad y creerme era muy curioso a
pesar de que tiene una cara un poco de
dormido en esas fotos que encontrado es
un enorme curiosidad le permitió
establecer sus vocaciones sus metas en
la vida necesitaba un ingrediente más
para poder conseguirlas y ese es el
segundo ingrediente del que os quiero
hablar hoy determinación sin esa
determinación sin esa fuerza de voluntad
y perseverancia por conseguir algo que
realmente nos apasiona sería imposible
superar todos los retos que aparecen en
nuestras vidas y es que creo que esta
persona sea el cosquín es un gran
ejemplo de como
la curiosidad nos permite fijar cuáles
son nuestras metas entender qué es lo
que queremos hacer en la vida y trazar
un camino para llegar a ellas pero que
sin determinación en los primeros
desafíos que encontramos en nuestro
camino nos quedaríamos parados y nos
convertiríamos en ese gran colectivo que
sí sueña pero no hace con esa
determinación podemos pasar al verdadero
aprendizaje y tener un verdadero impacto
en el mundo como queremos conseguir
por desgracia tchaikovsky no vivió para
ver volar ninguno de sus diseños porque
estaba muy adelantado a su tiempo sin
embargo todo lo que hizo sentó las bases
para que pudiéramos salir ahí fuera y
llegar a la luna y no solamente eso fue
el inicio de la era espacial la historia
le recordará como uno de los padres de
la astronáutica
lo bonito de la ciencia es que nunca se
termina nunca está completa aunque hoy
en día tenemos la tecnología para salir
ahí fuera y efectivamente para poner
hombres en la luna aunque no lo hacemos
desde los años 70
no tenemos una tecnología capaz de
llevarnos mucho más allá de una forma
efectiva
los cohetes que poseemos funcionan
mediante una reacción de combustión
queman un combustible con oxígeno para
producir ese chorro de fuego que sale
disparado vale pero veréis hay un
parámetro muy importante que dicta como
deficiente es un cohete la velocidad a
la que expulsamos los gases del motor
cohete cuanto más alta es esta velocidad
menos propulsantes necesitamos llegar a
bordo y esto es importante porque cuanto
más por pulsante tiene nuestra nave
necesitamos un lanzador más grande y por
lo tanto más caro y lo que es aún peor
cuanto más lejos queremos llegar el
coste en pro pulsante que necesitamos
llevar con nosotros en la nave aumenta
exponencialmente y esta subida dramática
de la cantidad de propulsión de que
necesitamos hace que rápidamente las
misiones más interesantes se conviertan
en inviables
es por ello que miles de científicos e
ingenieros en todo el mundo estamos
trabajando por intentar sobrepasar esos
límites que nos tienen la propulsión
química y para ello estamos intentando
buscar otras tecnologías alternativas
que nos permitan llegar a velocidades de
escape de los gases mucho más altas la
más prometedora de todas ellas es sin
duda la propulsión por plasma donde en
lugar de depender de una reacción de
combustión que nos pone una limitación
muy clara a esa velocidad de gases
lo que hacemos es utilizar la potencia
eléctrica de los paneles solares de
nuestra nave para primero ionizar el pro
pulsante y después acelerarlo el
resultado un chorro de plasma es decir
una mezcla de iones y electrones todos
revueltos a altísima velocidad de hecho
tan alta como nosotros queramos el único
límite sería la velocidad de la luz esto
nos permite abordar misiones que de otra
manera serían imposibles de abordar
como podéis imaginar desarrollar un
motor de plasma no es algo sencillo
hoy en día la propulsión eléctrica nadie
tiene duda de que va a jugar un papel
fundamental en el futuro de la carrera
espacial
de hecho tiene ya tanto éxito que si
pensamos solamente en los satélites que
están en torno a la tierra y las
misiones robóticas que se han mandado
por ahí un tercio de todos ellos ya
utiliza propulsor por plasma debido a
los grandes ahorros de propulsión de que
supone
como os decía no es fácil desarrollar un
motor de plasma requiere de grandes
instalaciones laboratorios donde se
pueda simular las condiciones del
espacio en cámaras de vacío requiere
conocer muchas cosas de la física de
plasmas para entender cómo funcionan
estos elementos y también requiere de
nuestras dos herramientas más
importantes la determinación y la
curiosidad de un niño para hacernos las
preguntas verdaderamente importantes y
así podernos plantear hacer cosas nuevas
pues como se suele decir el experimento
más valioso no es el que demuestra lo
que ya sabemos porque de alguna manera
valida lo que ya sabemos si no el que
nos deja pensando eso es interesante los
motores más exitosos son los que veis
aquí el motor iónico y el motor efecto
hole pero ya estamos trabajando en otras
muchas tecnologías que prometen superar
con creces las ya inigualables
prestaciones de estos motores
mirando atrás creo que en ese momento en
esa noche en las cañadas del teide lo
que ocurrió realmente es que la
curiosidad me pescó con su anzuelo y
desde entonces me hizo que mi motivación
mi vocación en la vida fuera contribuir
de alguna manera con mi granito de arena
a esa gran aventura de conquistar el
espacio mi elección fue hacerlo
desarrollando tecnologías necesarias
para movernos por él pero sin duda hay
muchas más maneras de contribuir a esta
gran empresa
aunque a veces el sistema en concreto el
educativo tiende a aplanar nuestra
curiosidad a acallar nuestras
inquietudes y hacernos a todos iguales
creo que es muy importante que no
olvidemos la importancia de esa edad
pura porque es la que nos hace ser
mejores aprender y superarnos
hace ya mucho tiempo que llegamos a
todos rincones del planeta y también
hace tiempo que llegamos a la luna ides
entonces no hemos vuelto a ir quiero
pensar que en un futuro no muy lejano
volveremos a salir ahí fuera nos
atreveremos a abandonar la comodidad de
lo conocido para volver a salir al
espacio y conquistarlo esta vez sí para
el bien de la humanidad
pues como dijo si al cosquín no podemos
permanecer en nuestra cuna para siempre
os pido que cuando lleguéis a vuestras
casas penséis en reconectar con esa
curiosidad de niño que tenéis dentro y
que os anima a haceros las mejores
preguntas que no dejéis de haceros
preguntas y de llegar hasta el fondo de
la madriguera que no olvidéis que todos
somos científicos y exploradores y que
dejéis que la curiosidad sea la
verdadera intención que guíe vuestra
atención
espero que pase lo que pase lo hagáis y
lo hagáis con determinación pues si lo
hacéis aunque no se viene a donde se que
llegaréis lejos gracias
[Aplausos]